oh my god it's a dog and so
i it's a special dog
like i are you crying right now thinking
about our dog
oh she's really never loved the dog so
much
yo so with this woman right
we're walking the dog and she knows that
i was a dog trainer and you know
i've taught you you are so mean i know
what this is
i was not you you hey we had a mediator
in
five four three two one
hello everybody this is the genius brain
podcast today we are here from manila
and i want you to know that you are very
special and i love you very much
thank you for calling customer service
this is
janelle speaking how are you today have
you actually been
in the philippines i have never really
i've been to
the philippines before and the only
place i've been is manila
oh really and it is what were you doing
in the philippines
uh my friend was there and we planned to
go
you know go to the beach side
that didn't happen i just got stuck in
manila for a week
and boy was that a disaster it is i
don't get it manila is so
sketchy so sketchy really yes so sketchy
that you
are never allowed to walk outside
you go from a car to a building to
another building
if you're outside it's very dangerous
they have rifle guns in front of
supermarkets oh really security guards
there are two security guards
with a rifle and before you go inside a
supermarket you have to get
everything checked kind of like uh
lax where everything needs to be checked
you go through
meta metal detector i think something
like that
and why'd you go to wait is so manila
manila is
uh is that like the capital or something
yeah yeah yeah but it's really
impoverished yeah so where do people
stay at when they go on vacation then
like a resort
yeah the the i don't oh i don't know
the philippines well but you know they
have the but that's not in manila then
no no that's like on the outside coastal
area
yeah manila is in the center of the
why'd you why'd you go if you're gonna
go in
because we were planning to go to the
beach but
uh i don't know what happened with a
typhoon no
i don't know i was with him my friend
and her relatives i don't know
somehow we didn't end up going there so
we ended up going to a
fake uh resort where they had beach but
like
it was whatever and then there were a
lot of donkeys
that we could ride on and so we did that
and i thought i was gonna die because
there was no safety gear
it was just a dude behind me who was
teasing me because i got so scared
so he kept making the donkey run faster
go faster
go past her make her more scared she's
going to do it anyways
i mean like all the rich people they go
to the malls the big malls and just
hang out eat yeah it's weird because
there's so many call when we so
this past year mary and i you know i've
we said it before that we were supposed
to go to vietnam
and so in order for us well after the
whole quarantine happened and the whole
kova situation happened we
were trying to get our refund back so we
got our first refund back right
and i remember before she was so adamant
that we buy the tickets she was like
what's the worst that could happen
and then all the airways got shut in
vietnam and so we're still waiting for
the four thousand dollars back which i
said remember
that we shouldn't do it actually
that's not how it went because wait are
you talking about the first one in a
second the second one the second one i
said we shouldn't do it
the second one no we were still gonna do
it because our friends already bought
the tickets
no i said that we shouldn't do it
then why did we do it because you wanted
to go no
yeah you said that you said that it's
like it's okay it's gonna be fine
lynn and vince are doing it
yeah and i said i didn't want to
remember that's right the truth is
coming out everybody thank you so much
yeah yeah yeah it doesn't make sense
because this was
your present for me so why would i
decide
what we finally got i was like cool well
let's
yeah and who got that money back for you
the that experience
was the worst okay let me tell let me
tell the story what that's going on
right so you want to go ahead tell your
story i don't care
so literally every morning on my way to
work which is about 40 minute of commute
i'll be on the phone with which one was
it viama
it was viola yeah vyama waiting still
waiting for my [ __ ] money back by the
way
actually vyama gave us our money back
the second one
the second one from a different company
oh is it hey thank you by them i
appreciate it so much wait i don't
know that it's the second review i don't
know was the second one too we ordered
on vayama again
i don't no i don't think yes it is i'm
the one still getting the emails right
now from vayama
anyway so keep calling and literally
it took me two weeks every day calling
and no joke
i'd be on the phone for like two to
three hours waiting and waiting and i
would
get in touch with someone and then that
person put me on hold and then transfer
me to someone
and sometimes the line gets caught up
out of nowhere and so
they're trying to break your spirit
that's why yeah they're trying to be
like okay let's see
i'm sorry i'm sorry mom sir uh what
happened was the line got cut off but if
you will wait for just maybe 10 more
minutes
yeah and it's never 10 minutes every
time excuse me hello mom sir i'm so
sorry for the weight
um so yeah i was doing that for two
weeks and i finally got the refund
and then within 24 hours we lost
half of that money again by purchasing
another ticket because we thought it
would be fine
but it wasn't so i'm still out four
grand right now
yep four thousand dollars come on by
emma give us our money back
uh if you would like to talk to my
manager
please hold and i'm like no no no i
don't want to hold because i know what
you're going to do you're going to hold
me on here for about two hours
they'll come back they're like thank you
for waiting for your patience ma'am sir
uh can you please uh tell me the the
code that you have for the ticket
and i'll tell them okay this is what we
can do we can give you a partial refund
and i'm like no
no partial refund do we even got that i
don't even got the option of that
they're just like you need to contact
the actual airline
and get the refund and i'm like okay the
first one was
the first one wasn't vyama then yeah
it's not vyama i told you
see everybody listen no no no earlier
you said the second one
yeah no you said it wasn't one of them
is actually i don't know which one but i
know they're not from
the second one the second one is what i
was saying because i'm the one dealing
with it right now with the emails
so the yeah so they're not the same
company exactly you said the first one
was byyama you'll see it on the footage
i said one of them was i said they're
not from the same company oh my god
i'm so glad this is being recorded right
it's being recorded so glad this is
being recorded right now
remember i said one of them i don't i
don't think i don't appreciate the way
you're talking to me
uh anyway so uh
yeah yeah so it's weird because when you
listen to a filipino call center
you you can't even get mad at them is
because they are literally
reading off a piece of paper and the
reason why i know that is because every
time i called back it was the same spiel
same sentence same everything so no
matter how mad that you get
they're really not even listening to
what the [ __ ] you're saying they just
know that
if they yell i say line number 42
and if i say line 42 this is going to be
their response
their response is about three options
they're either going to be mad
be happy as for manager and so i will go
to option 17.
so this is how they just read this
[ __ ] piece of paper
and they just keep going and so i just
sat there i remember i was like they're
reading a piece of paper to me right now
they're not even listening so they're
you know they're doing their job i think
like filipino customer service
is the best to deal with angry people
because there's no emotions involved
they just kind of say what they have to
say
it's true filipinos and indians
oh we didn't get indian call center we
got all filipinos oh i'm talking about
other customer services when it's indian
oh it's from india yeah but when i do
like from verizon
for example right you will usually get a
a rep from india but when you get it
from the us it's a whole different
conversation i'm i sometimes i just like
should i am i
allowed to get mad right now because
you're about to talk back to me
i mean you could always like that's why
they always ask for the manager then you
could ask but i've
it's been pretty decent except for
uh southwest southwest i had a problem
with i think i think i got somebody
fired from there
oh i had a problem with chase oh really
one time this was years ago when someone
gave me an attitude
i forget what the problem was but i
called customer service i was like
infuriated because the guy would
be so rude to me that um
i called back and asked for the
supervisor
and the supervisor gave me a call back
and apologized
it's hard though sometimes sometimes
when you talk to customer service but i
hear it
you're upset yeah if i have to wait for
two weeks
yeah for hours and i'm working
that's the hard part because i remember
one time she was i was hearing her talk
to customer service and she said a
phrase
that what did i say for what i forgot
what it was for but remember i stopped
it i was like
i could see why that person was a little
irritated at you it was because you were
saying something
i think like what happens sometimes it's
like when you say these words it doesn't
translate very well right
so when you're angry nothing translates
well no but you weren't angry though
that's the thing like you said something
like in an american phrase
where if you say that it sounds very
aggressive but you weren't but you
weren't
i remember what it is i don't remember
what it was for but i said
did you want me to do that or am i
supposed to do it or something like that
yeah like something like that and i was
like
that's very combative you know but in
your mind you're just asking a question
like am i supposed to do this
but what it sounded like when you were
talking to the customer service person
is like oh
you're asking me to do it that's how i
perceived it you know but then i saw
your face
and i was like oh she's not upset she's
just asking but just from hearing it
verbally it sounded like you were you
were telling them like what am i
supposed to do your job for you
that's what it sounded like it's not
always like that though and then when i
heard the guy he could tell he was a
little pissed i was like
i could kind of see it but if you saw
your face he would have known that you
weren't upset
you were just asking see that's the
benefit of my face is that a lot of the
times
it's like you know i have to agree that
i do
and did have those kind of uh moments
because
when i was in college my first year i
tore my first year i met you know i made
some friends
and one of the friends was really blunt
like she's very uh
she's a gr she was a great friend who
was very honest about everything right
so she
later on she'd be like man girl
sometimes you could be very ditzy
but with that face like you're very
forgiving and i'm like what do you mean
she's like you
just sometimes you say things and i'm
just like girl what is wrong with you
and i look at your face but like oh
you're so innocent though
i was like oh it's like but that's a
good thing and i'm like okay
okay she was like a senior i think she
wasn't seen she was a senior yeah
she gave me that i still remember that i
was like oh
am i ditzy but i think i was just i
think i'm just i was just really
innocent back then and so i would say
things but then because
how i look or like how i'm presenting
myself
i'm i'm not meeting it in a bad way you
have a very weird
you're hard to understand because you i
think it's because you hopped around so
much
like you you're missing certain like
cultural pieces
like cultural nuances when you speak
english like you don't
yeah yeah like certain phrases that you
don't know that can be really offensive
absolutely like you don't know that it
is you know i mean so it's very weird
like for here's a great example too like
this is why i say too it's it's hard to
judge people uh
just with blanket thoughts right and
what i mean by that and that's not a
very good way to explain what i'm
talking about but
let me just explain it's like for
example um
i always talk about intent right when
people have conversations with people
and how they perceive things and how you
deal with very awkward situations
and the reason why i say that number one
it helps you to be less combative and
number two it allows you to be
empathetic towards somebody else's
situation
uh so for example i grew up very
fortunate where i say that i grew up
around a lot of different cultures so i
have this lens and this view
of understanding how to tiptoe around um
very awkward cultural situations because
i've already been around it since i was
younger
right so for example like i remember
when marielle first met khalif maryland
the cliff and said
hey can i touch your hair and i looked
at her i was like don't do that she goes
why i just want to touch your hair and i
explained to her
i was like would you like a random
person that you just met come up and
run their fingers through your hair i
was like to you it seems innocent
because it's different from your hair so
you want to know what it feels like
yeah but to them it's just their hair
yeah so you can't just go up and just
start asking somebody can i touch your
hair it makes them feel like they're an
object
you know and for her that's something
that i've seen a lot of people do
that just never grew around grew up
around black people right or just black
cultural in general so i know
intent wise it's just oh your hair is
different than mine it would be nice if
i could touch it to see the difference
however it's it's a very awkward thing
to do when they when you kind of take a
step back and you kind of reverse the
situation
you know so if somebody can get really
mad at somebody for um
in that but if you look back and say oh
i actually never grew up around black
people black culture or anything else so
i didn't know that was a weird thing
you know so it's like i've definitely
have to sometimes like
i want to say help people per se but
help them to understand that right
because
social media has allowed a lot of these
kids just to get mad
at people in an instant without
empathizing without kind of putting
themselves
in their shoes and i always say too when
some of these kids they send me these
articles
about these people who you know have
these racist things that happen i'll
take a step back i look at i'm like
that's not racist
that person actually had really good
intentions he just obviously didn't grow
up around the culture so he doesn't know
so instead of taking a point to educate
somebody in some of these situations and
talking to them have a
normal [ __ ] human conversation you're
so busy getting cool points recording
this so you could send it to me so i
could trash this person
so you don't have a good intent you're
actually not a good person at all
because what you're trying to do is gain
social currency by [ __ ] on somebody
because it's the cool thing to do
rather than saying like oh this is a
this is an opportunity for me to talk to
somebody and
and help them learn and understand so
that's why i i think it's very odd when
people just expect people to understand
their culture when nobody has introduced
a culture to them at
all you know it's it's true i mean i
think i'm very fortunate i do
have a look where i could get that
pass um but i mean it doesn't mean it's
a good thing i think i learned a lot
from that that i just needed to be a
little bit more aware but
something like that where i've never
experienced it was my first time seeing
you know it was my first time seeing
that hair so i'm just like
and it's so close to me and but at the
same time after you explained it like it
totally made sense that
it could be very inappropriate and
you know it's this podcast is brought to
you by
skillshare my friends what is skillshare
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes for creative and curious people
you can explore new skills deepen
existing passions and just get lost in
creativity
listen i like learning on my own accord
there are so many things that i want to
learn like whether it's photography
videography graphic design
whatever you name it i need courses that
i can access whenever i want and however
i want by credible people and that's
what skillshare has
i'm pretty sure if you're like me out
there and you want to learn something
new you have to
scour the internet for for teachers
lessons or courses
skillshare has your back it makes things
so easy
right now i'm actually learning how to
do iphone videography through a course
on skillshare and it's super fun
uh an iphone essentially is a camera
that we didn't have even 10 years ago
with a lot of these dslrs so
if i'm out traveling and i want to keep
things really small i was like okay well
why don't i just use my iphone well they
have a course on how to maximize your
cinematography and filmmaking abilities
with your iphone and i love
that course my friends for you
right now my genius brain listeners
explore your creativity at
skillshare.comgb
and get a free trial of premium
membership that's skillshare.comgb once
again that's
s-k-i-l-l-s-h-a-r-e
dot com slash gb till this day
like i'm still learning american culture
like when i
you know i started working in an
american company five years ago
and from there on i've learned so much
about american culture of like
how people work with one another things
that they can say
um and you know when i
went to my fir when i went to my
university which was um
it was university of san diego before i
went to berkeley it was full of white
people there were only literally a
handful of asians
and prior to that i was living in an
asian bubble
it was all asian they were barely rarely
any other
race and so when i went to that school
honestly it was really hard for me to
adjust
because nobody looked like me and nobody
had the same
interest as me you know i loved watching
anime but these girls
like to go you know i don't know go be
part of sorority or something
and i was like what the hell is sorority
so
it and then you know
you want to be part of something and so
i tried
i think i tried really hard to be to
blend in
and then part of that was kind of being
a ditzy at the same time just so that
i could get that attention i guess um
oh i would have hated you [ __ ]
i holiday [ __ ] i don't know i mean at
the end of the day i didn't make any
white friends
i ended up sticking with my asian
friends
because it was hard for me to be around
people like that at the time that people
weren't really grow
but you know at the same time you're 18
years old i mean who am i to tell
somebody like oh you're not a grounded
person because i wasn't grounded at 18
either i don't know i was totally
exploring myself who i am and then when
i came back
from uh was it when i came when i went
back home
during like winter break or something my
friends and even my parents were like
well you're so different
oh really yeah not in a bad way it's
just the way i was
maybe just like the way i was talking i
was talking much faster for some reason
um and no joke i didn't understand
korean
when i went back i was like what
happened to me i don't understand what
they're saying i don't know how to speak
korean like
it was a huge like i am very easy to
adapt to new environment
that's the one thing is that if i get
into a new environment i could absorb
so well that i actually could forget
other things that i've learned is that a
good thing or a bad thing too
that's hard for me like i can't i think
for me if i was younger
and i had and i met you at the time i
probably wouldn't have liked you because
i
i hate that i probably wouldn't have
hung out with you either
well i'm not saying as it did i'm just
saying like for you it's like that
that in college that behavior was
something that i had trouble what was
the behavior
people who would flip their
personalities i don't flip it's not that
i'm flipping is that i could adjust to
it so
going from 100 asian community to
100 white community that's a huge change
and i was able to survive not
being a fake person but adjusting to the
new environment yeah i think we all have
that adjustment thing right
we make those tweaks here and there yeah
that doesn't mean i was
not myself it was just i was also
exploring myself i mean i'm
outside of my bubbles like okay let's
see what what's out there you know
i go and have party with this crew and i
will have party with other crew
and just like really like expanding my
network and seeing what
where i fit but along that experience
i am changing i'm molding into one thing
into another thing
so when i come back home i am a little
bit different
the way i talk is different the way uh
maybe the way i talk is different the
way things i used to do might change
might have changed
one thing that i did realize is that i
lost
my touch um how to speak korean so when
i went to korea that
uh winter i had a hard time
communicating with my family and friends
over there
so you're just kind of extreme though do
you see what i'm saying because i
remember even when uh we were dating
when we were going on the first couple
years i mean i think you and i got into
a few arguments but i just i didn't like
how sometimes you would
um kind of do do you do that it's kind
of extreme
you know you know what i mean it i think
it's called survival mode
but it was like for me i'm not it's a
quality that i just don't like
you know what i mean that i could mold
into something no it's not molding but
it's like
you you kind of change your personality
for a specific
group not in the sense that i can it's
not as extreme as i'm saying it right
it's actually very minor right it's just
one of my personal pet peeves
right so for example like uh like i said
we all have these things where you know
obviously if i'm in a professional
setting
i'll be a little more professional right
because it's a work setting if i'm in a
party setting it's going to be you know
part of david's going to come out
but i think like for example like you
like when you hang out with lin
you hate when you hang out with lin
you're you're the way that you speak
your cadence and everything starts to
mold to how lin speaks
right and that would be the stuff that
remember i see an argument about you
with that stuff because like every time
you hang out with her you'd be like
okay girl i'm like what the [ __ ] what is
this it's the person that i
i didn't date that person uh-huh you
know what i mean who did you date
huh you the person that's talking right
now you know
and i think for you sometimes like when
you get out of your element what you do
is that you you try to
mold into that you know but you don't
have to it's what i'm saying
it's like you're perfectly fine the way
that you are and that person will
appreciate who you are
as you are i think that's the one thing
i
did learn like from from
not from that um from
college till now i think i have i mean
obviously that's been that's been a
while
and i've changed a lot and i think
really from
last year's where i really thought to
myself like
some just some stuff let's just say it's
at work or personal life i'd be like i
don't care
i don't give a um because
this is who i am and if you don't like
me for who i am if you think i'm too
asian for those are not wide enough and
i can't
you know joke around with certain types
of jokes
i don't care and that's it really hit me
in my
30s i think prior to that
my 29 and you know 20
21 to 29 i think i still have moments
where i want to blend in
i mean till this day like some you know
obviously you guys all do it to a
certain extent that's what i'm saying
like i think it's smart for people to do
it to a certain yeah
i think my foundation definitely has
grown
in my 30s in my 30s and i think it's
also because i have
stayed in one location for a really long
time it's my first time ever staying in
one location
for more than two years prior to that
like i had to live in different
countries
adjust a different culture and get along
with people you know and so
i think i was so used to that that maybe
my foundation just wasn't
really grounded and then it was until
i think it also kind of stems just from
now that you know that i've obviously
known you for like six years now
it's you know you've always had a very
uh tumultuou tumultuous like upbringing
like you were always traveling here here
and there here and there so fitting in
for you was something that you had to
learn how to do
and you had to do it really fast because
you just kept moving all the time
you know versus somebody like me i
stayed in sacramento for a fat chunk of
my life except for the last like 12
years
you know so i was a sacramento kid
that's who i was
i had i still had the same friends since
junior high in high school till this day
same friends from elementary school
you know we still kick it even for
thanksgiving we did a zoom thanksgiving
friendsgiving you know
i don't know what that means and what
that feels like because
it's it was a struggle i mean it was it
was a curse and a blessing at the same
time because
when you're traveling you get to really
experience
so many things right but at the same
time you don't know
where you're where to balance it's like
it's like you said it feels like
survival mode right it's like okay
do i how long am i going to be here for
right do i have enough time for me to be
this person and these people to get used
to it and then this whole adaptation
fit i might as well just go ahead and
adjust to what they do and then who
knows how long i'm gonna be here
you know and i think for me seeing that
from you as an adult kind of surprised
me
because uh i usually tend to stray away
from that type of behavior
and you're with one because with me like
i'm
pretty much who i am throughout no
matter what right so it's either you
you take me for who i am or or you don't
and you can be happy with that and i can
be happy with that
right sure which is why i'm a very i'm a
very polarizing person like i
either you love me or you [ __ ] hate
me right but if you love me you love me
to death if you hate me you [ __ ] hate
me to death sure and so that's really
what it is
you know so like when i saw you do a
little bit of that i was kind of shocked
because
i thought i'm like in my mind i'm like
you're perfectly fine you don't have to
mold the way that she speaks or the way
that she does things
and you're you know it's almost like
it's a trait for me
i think it's a trait for during my
survival mode that i
tend to pick on uh it could be a habit
that i just kind of go along and how
people do it doesn't mean i'm changing
it's just in that moment
it's that survival mode kicks in where
it's a habit that i had that i go along
with how
this community uh communicates with each
other
you know what i mean yeah it's just like
i'm saying like for me it was very
hard to watch so how did you overcome
that we got into a couple of fights
about it
and then you stopped it
did i yeah because she used to do this
thing where whenever you hung out with
specifically her right because linda and
i have been friends for
what i don't know 20 years now you know
so the way lin and i behave and we talk
to each other
it's very uh it it's very specific to us
right and but i have a very specific
relationship with you that i like that i
cherish
but then i think when you saw how she
and i were you would try to do whatever
how she i was like who is this person
like
there's a reason why lynn is my friend
and you're my fiance
you know like don't do what she does
because then
i'm attracted to mariel you know what i
mean don't don't do that
you know do i do that with anyone else
that like recently has
anything no you ha not after we got into
those couple big fights like you haven't
really done it
well not in front of me anyways you know
because it's just
you know and i and i and by the way when
i when i encapsulate this in this
conversation
it's it's very you know particular very
specific
so like i said when you're in a
professional setting yeah you should
behave a little more professionally
when you're with your friends you know
you're allowed to do that but i'm
talking about foundation shifts right
where the person becomes a completely
different person
that's the stuff that always makes me
uneasy so even with some of my friends
from back home right
i have a buddy of mine that you've met
him right
she met one of my friends right and this
dude so this guy is hilarious
so this guy you know uh went to the
military at a very young age
um pretty much out of high school
a lot of my friends who did go to the
military there were kind of like hood
you know what i'm saying like they
that's who they are
yeah they're very hood they kind of stay
in this time capsule where they are who
they are when they
when they were in high school and when
they left they come back they're still
the same person
a lot of us have moved past a lot of the
shenanigans and the stuff that we say
and do so for example
when he when he left the uh to go into
the military
and we kind of went to college or we did
something else we met a lot of different
people and we kind of kept up with the
times we stopped using the n-word
yeah you know what i mean which he can
he's like you know he's half black
whatever right so he's
his n-word is like like for us
yeah well that's how it was for all of
us back in the day
but then for my back in the day it was
so for him you know what i mean like
i mean nobody's gonna say he's half
black so it's like you know but still
when we're out in the street and i'm
hanging out and like i'm talking about
when she first met this dude right
where we're shooting something and he
comes up and he tells me he's in la i'm
like yo
come through i haven't seen you in a hot
second we're gonna be at a bar anyways
we'll get something to eat we'll drink
whatever
he comes out the first thing he says he
goes hey what's up
and i'm like hey bro times have changed
man you can't just be screaming that
word you know
but you know it it's i think for her it
was very
uh shocking yeah it is very shocking
because
a i've never met anyone who would say
that
out loud so much
and b he to be honest like i grew up in
a very
safe community where uh in my bubble
uh that type of word that type of
you know body language was very foreign
yes so but see but somebody like him and
i was explaining to her and remember she
asked me she goes
why are you friends with somebody like
that and and the the key
important factor that i have to say why
i said how how
how you know and my what i always say
when it comes to
people who have been in my life for a
very long time they always share this
one quality in one trade
is that they're loyal as [ __ ] right and
they are always who they are no matter
what
and the reason why that's important to
me is because it develops
uh a relationship of trust i o i will
always know who this person is and i
will always know what their foundation
is
so if something bad happens to me it's
not because
of what they did right this podcast is
brought to you by warby
parker my friends if you wear glasses or
sunglasses you need to get on
warby parker it's probably the easiest
buying experience for eyewear i have
ever had in my life hands down
you know one of the coolest things that
you can do with warby parker is actually
getting to try on
five of their glasses or sunglasses with
their home try on kit
to see how they look and feel all you
got to do is take a quick quiz
pick out your glasses then boom is at
your doorstep ready to try on when
you're done there's a prepaid shipping
level and you just ship it right back
how dope is that listen if you can make
online shopping for something as fickle
as
i wear convenient and fun you got my
money you got my time you got my
support oh and by the way if there's
more than like five that you want to try
on i actually found out that if you go
through their app
you can virtually try them on as well
high tech and it's actually surprisingly
accurate
the quality variety look and feel of
their products are amazing as well you
won't be disappointed and i gotta say
i look good in my shades your boy's
styling try warby parker's free home try
on program order five pairs of glasses
to try at home for free
for five days there's no obligation to
buy it's ships free and once again it
includes a prepaid
return shipping label try five pairs of
glasses at home for free
at warbyparker.com gb
once again that's w-a-r-b-y
dot com slash gb even if they did
something wrong
i know who that person is and i chose to
stay around they've always been upfront
and honest about who they are
so if i'm around that person and they
have stated to me from the
get-go and from the jump and they've
been consistent with who they are
if something around me bad happens
because of that person
i take responsibility for that because i
chose to be around somebody they didn't
change
they are who they are so this is these
are the friendships that i have right
did you grow up with him like did you
guys go to the same
yep elementary school okay high school
junior high everything he's actually one
of the he's one of those guys that got
me into a lot of trouble
you know it's interesting because what
are the
say it again what are the uh things that
you look into
it's mainly loyalty and then knowing who
you are okay
loyalty and knowing who you are so funny
enough
i have different background as you were
most you've you already know but all my
groups are from
different different phase of my life
yeah and different location so they
could be from korea or
from school or from taiwan so they're
from everywhere and they're all very
different right
but the one thing the reason the one
thing
is that the reason why we are all still
friends is because
they they put
so much effort to keep in touch with me
and i do as well
and i put that as my loyalty too
is that they're so loyal that they
really cherish our
limited time that we had as friendship
that they
till this day whether that's two years
three seven
ten years ago that we still keep in
touch
and that's
it it's it's interesting because you and
i come from a different background
different types of friends um but
the value that i still cherish and the
value that i look into
is that all of these friends are very
loyal to me and i am very loyal to them
obviously
and that's the reason why i'm still
friends with them yeah yeah yeah yeah
um but they are all very different
because they
are we develop friendship at a specific
time of my life so that that phase i was
friends with them
um and of course in that group of
friends like i may not talk to like
80 of them but 20 of them we have
very similar value that we still keep in
touch
yeah yeah i mean that's that's the
a lot of people have hard times
developing those type of friendships
because i think
we're so used to developing
relationships based on what we can
gain from somebody right which you know
friendships too
it is a give and take thing right you
you gain you gaining a friendship
that's something that you'll gain out of
it right right but in terms of like very
specific things
you know not just in this city but just
the way
i think like the youth like their mind
has been set up it's like it's always
about
grinding heart coming up getting people
to watch me look at me
and so when you have that that goal in
mind that also
affects your personal relationships
because now you're only thinking like
well this person isn't going to help me
grow that's that's like the hottest
thing right now right they go if you
ain't going to help me grow why do i
have you with my life
you know yeah that's like the thing out
of touch would it well that's
that's what people say it's like if you
ain't going to help me grow you
shouldn't be in my life but
to me that's [ __ ] dumb because
sometimes friendships aren't about like
your personal growth
your personal growth is your own [ __ ] i
understand that what you when you mean
when you say
um if people are if your friends are
going to bring you down
well clearly they're not your friends
but they shouldn't be here for your
personal growth yeah that's on you yeah
that's your [ __ ]
find a mentor then yeah sometimes your
friends are just there to be your
friends
to laugh to joke around you know to talk
about the past just hang around and do
absolutely [ __ ] nothing there are
friends that i have right now in my life
that if you look at what they do they're
just just really happy-go-lucky people
but they don't have these
business aspirations they don't have you
know
they're not typically what you would
think of a very highly successful person
but they're some of my closest friends
yeah i'm not around there because we're
hustling and we're grinding together
yeah you know it's this stupid idea and
this is this is so dumb like i hate that
phrase because it's like if you're not
there to help me grow
that's not on your friends to do that
your friends are there to be your friend
that's funny i'm so glad i was born in
this generation because i don't think
any of us think like that
i am in the entertainment field where
you
could gain those kind of quote-unquote
friends but
i think i am very well protected and
also very
self-aware to know who are out there to
just
have that specific goal and it is so
obvious though and i don't
i don't like it personally but i'm so
glad that i'm not in that generation
is that what you hear from your no it's
just the general truth it's just
everybody around me is kind of like that
and these are people i'm by the way
they're they're not
my friends yeah you know what i mean
like here's a great example so mariel
and i i took her to
this one event where it was uh like a
social
influencer event right where you go
around they give you free stuff if you
like it you could post for them or
whatever oh yeah
that was so weird right that was the
first one that i went to too
yeah right and i was like we weren't
doing anything and in my mind i'm like
free [ __ ]
all right let's go and so we went to do
our asian thing where we heard free
samples and we're like
hey free sample let's do it baby and so
we went there
and one of the most disgusting behaviors
that i've ever
seen was this this young girl
and so when you get there if you're a
quote unquote influencer they gave you
like this concierge that would just take
walk you around they would hold your
bags or whatever and all your stuff for
us
that was a weird part which is weird
right and our guy was like hey i was
like you know what dude
give me my stuff you go do whatever like
you don't you don't have to do this
right you're like oh no they talked like
relax you showed me what to do
i'm gonna walk around you don't need to
hold my bags you're good man just go
have fun go get some food and drink some
whatever and we sent the guy away right
but then there was one girl and they
have their
influence so they have an assistant with
them right their concierge
and that concierge has a name tag around
them of that person's
instagram handle right and so what
they're doing so they'll hold their bags
with them and they'll basically cater to
whatever they want
and this young girl had her [ __ ] nose
so
far up her own [ __ ] ass it was so
irritating right
because the way that she was i just was
listening the way that she would boss
this person around right as if
as if she owned the dude right and i'm
looking at this girl like who the [ __ ]
is this little [ __ ]
and so and i just look i'm like staring
at her like
who are you and so i was like all right
cool so i remember i looked down and i
and i looked up her name she had like 3
000 followers on instagram
and that's who and i'm like hold on a
second
i know personal friends about 3 000
they're not any influencer at all
and it's weird like they feel like they
have to act a certain way be a certain
way
fake it till you make it type of thing
right and they and they behave this way
because they feel like this is what they
have to do in order to be a popular or a
recognized human being
and it's [ __ ] disgusting and that's
the type of behavior that i hate
you know and i'm watching this [ __ ] and
in my mind i'm like you're a [ __ ]
nobody
you're literally a nobody right in terms
of this space
right you haven't even if you earned
your way up to a certain standard
there's no way you should treat somebody
like and i think the phrase faking you
make it is that's not how you do it
it's it's it's like dude if you want to
get respect
if you want to get respect respect other
people too
you know what i mean like it's it's
called
karma one thing but i think
i truly believe that in order to
be successful you got to respect every
single person
and if i i just don't
i mean people that's just disgusting
it's just like one day it's kind of hit
you really bad like how
foolish you were that's why i get scared
sometimes to like
when we have a kid ourselves you know
like
where i wonder how well we're gonna do
as parents
you know only because there's i i still
i'm a very goofy funny dude but when it
comes to like
in terms of parenting and um kind of
being involved in
even like our dog right i'm a lot more
strict than mariel is
i'm yeah i'm very very strict you know
yes you are
and um i think you know one thing i i do
i'm pretty confident is that neither of
us are going to be
uh we're not going to spoil our kid
because we didn't grow up that way
yeah i mean people because my parents
might have a different thought about
this but
even the way i give my treats to so it's
funny
the way you train riley it is very
strict
we have different uh part of
how we train our our dog
the way i train my dog is that you know
i love to give her treats but i will
give her
very little you know it's like you're
not gonna get big trees just because you
sat down
you you know you rolled over whatever
like you will do
five different tricks and i'll give you
a little treat
david on the other hand i'll just give
you a whole stack of beef
i don't give her a whole stack i don't
do tricks with her that's why
like i never he just wants to give love
and that's the way giving love is that
you know you like food so here's some
food for me it's like you like food but
you're gonna have to earn it
david on the other hand if i go for a
walk with riley
i just let her do whatever she wants
like sure i will try to train her but i
feel so bad because i don't go
out for a walk with her all the time so
when i do i'm like
do your thing whereas david is like nope
you're gonna learn how to walk with a
human
and there is no compromisation on that
confidence
compromisation yo you love that word
that where i
love that word thank you what's up y'all
want that compromisation baby
with my alexandria firmization
yeah there's no compromise on that and
so
because and the reason why and if we go
i know like dogs aren't kids like i know
the difference but
the reason why is because my dog is also
not somebody else's responsibility so if
my dog doesn't know how to behave itself
in public
and it makes other people uncomfortable
that's on me as the dog owner
so when we walk like so i was a dog
trainer for a little bit so in
california you actually don't have to be
licensed for it like it's
it's really weird i'm not i wasn't that
great of it i did it for about a year
right but one of the hardest things that
people had when it came to
you'd be surprised it's not teaching
your dog how to sit it's not teaching
your dog tricks
the thing that people can't [ __ ] do
is get their dog to walk
and the reason why is because it
requires patience and a lot of people
uh think that you're being very
oppressive to the dog that's how i feel
right yeah but what i always told people
when it came to dog training and this is
what i learned from the person who
taught me was that
you could have your dog explore and do
whatever that's fine
but you have to set those boundaries as
a pack leader right
so if it's time to walk it's time to
walk they'll sniff they'll smell things
they're having a good time their tail is
up
right but they can't do what they want
at will because you as a as a dog owner
when you're walking your dog you are
responsible for this dog and how it
behaves yeah right so that's why when
you see people walk in their dogs
something
they start and they go oh it's okay it's
like yeah it's okay for you because it's
your dog
that's not my dog you're making me feel
uncomfortable and a lot of people aren't
considerate in that case
so when you walk your dog and you're
training this dog when you're walking
with them they have to know
when we walk this is what we do at a
stop sign we stop here
when we stop and i say have fun smell
everything that you want at the dog park
have fun run around go in circles but
when we walk it's time to walk
you know and i think i think we i mean
obviously yeah you're right dogs and
babies are different stories but
in terms of like what we our goal to
achieve with this dog
i think hopefully that we will able to
uh apply the same thing to your kids
hopefully our kids will be
i i all i wish for my kid is to be
normal
have five fingers on each hand
healthy you want them yeah i want them
to be healthy
and that's all i could wish for at this
moment not me i want them to be healthy
and i want them to be happy have fun but
also no boundaries and i think that's
the
what i've been seeing too like i said
i'm always asking people who i feel like
are the best parents
in terms of what their kids look like
right because i've seen them grow up
sure
right and i'm always asking them
questions about how they did it and they
and and one of the things that i always
see from these people that i like
anyways is that
they were very good at setting
boundaries but also showing them a lot
of love
and i think for a lot of young parents
right now they're so
scared of like having their kids hate
them that they're
scared to set these boundaries that are
what they think is
toxic like parenting like telling them
not to do something setting certain
boundaries how they should do things
being like oh i'm stifling their
creativity
sure but there's a problem with that too
it because now
they're putting their own personal
issues that they have onto this child
right one of the biggest things that we
just had a conversation about this so i
have a
i have a friend of mine she uh she deals
with um she's a family therapist
right and um she says though one of the
biggest issues
that she has especially when
pharmaceutical or child therapist i
forgot what it was
i think it's a child therapist but
either way she she helps kids with like
um
like family problems and also like like
kids who have like motor function issues
like
speech therapist speech therapist i'm
sorry my bad she's a speech therapist is
this your friend
this podcast is brought to you by honey
imagine this you make a list of the
gifts you're gonna buy for the holidays
and then someone randomly gives you the
money to help you buy one
sound freaking good you bet your sweet
booty cheeks it does
well that's what honey is doing they're
helping pay for one million dollars
worth of gifts i'm not playing you're
probably wondering
is this the same honey that
automatically searches for promo codes
online and yes you sweet stupid stupid
people it is
with honey you can also make a list of
all the holiday gifts you want
from certain stores and honey will email
you when the price drops on anything on
your list
just add honey to your computer create a
free account and throw some holiday
gifts on your drop list for a chance
to win honey will randomly select
winners and give them the money to help
buy something
on their list you know what i'm going to
add on my drop list son
an espresso because your boy be liking
espressos
and my fiance wants one for her
christmas gift and i don't want to pay
for that [ __ ] so you best believe i'm
gonna put that on
there no purchase necessary you need a
paypal account to redeem the prize
only valid in the us giveaway ends on 12
21 20 20. get honey for free at
joinhoney.com
slash brain that's join honey.com
brain okay i'm sorry not a family
therapist i'm thinking family because
i'm thinking about a child but she's a
speech therapist
right so one of the things that i was
telling her about that she said she's
dealing with a lot of young parents
right now
is that their kids can't communicate
sure which is so [ __ ] fascinating in
my mind i'm like
what do you mean i thought we're in the
age now where parents want to have
conversations with their kids they want
to do
she goes yeah that's true but when
they're at a young age a lot of these
parents don't want their kids to face
any
any type of adversity but when you do
that it actually stifles their learning
sure and i was like what do you mean by
that i was like for example she goes a
lot of these kids are having commute
having trouble communicating what they
want because their parents are doing
things for them
yeah and i was like what do you mean by
that she goes for example if a kid comes
up and the kid goes
uh it starts whining or fussing or
crying
the child clearly wants to communicate
that it wants something right and this
is like in the stage where the kid can
kind of
verbalize what they want or show what
they want with their hands physically or
whatever
but before the child can express that a
parent will come in and just grab it for
them is this what you want here
yeah before they learn how to
communicate things verbally and deal
with their emotions
and so they're so scared for this kid to
face adversity to feel bad emotions and
bad thoughts
that she has to teach these parents like
hey you gotta allow these kids to
communicate
and then it goes deeper than that when
they're older when they face adversity
they feel like they shouldn't feel
sadness
they shouldn't feel pain and everything
should be happy yeah and so parents
basically
want to address the problem before they
feel
negative feelings yeah and by the way
this isn't i'm just regurgitating what
this conversation that i had with this
person that was a speech therapist
this is not me saying as somebody who
doesn't have kids i'm saying it from the
perspective of a person that deals with
this a lot it's funny because i
korean so these days korean in korea
there's a lot of
uh reality shows about parenting
and it's so fun and fascinating to see
it because they're usually
a therapist or professional who is there
to observe
and analyze how the parents are
interacting with the kids
and one of them it was like a do you
remember ses
yes so there's a cape first generation
k-pop group called
scs love them one of them had one of
them one of the ladies uh
was in a show called
i think superman returns uh it's
basically where a celebrity and the kid
are interacting with each other and they
what they like to do is that they like
to analyze how the parents
are interacting with the kids and this
family is like perfect everybody see
them as a perfect family
it turns out that the kid is actually
lacking in speech
because exactly what you said oh really
is that nuts
they're talking a lot the parents are
talking a lot oh but they're talking for
the kid huh for
the kids that's exactly what my friend
was saying yeah so that is the reason
why
her speech is actually a little bit
slower than the average and so
when they realized that and trying to
address this
the kid went blonkers she
started freaking out she started crying
whining and it
obviously it's so hard to watch that but
they had to overcome that
to have her talk for herself
because she was so accustomed to the
parents talking for her that she was
like wait a minute i don't understand
i all i had to do was look at something
you would tell me what i want
why is it that you're not getting that
for me and so she had to figure out how
to talk for herself
now she's fine she talks so well but
it's so fascinating to see that we see
this family as a perfect family
and yet there was a problem a huge
problem that could happen in the future
where
she would have had speech issue yeah
so watching these i'm like oh i'm
learning a lot i was like i would have
never thought of that
yeah and that's a generational gap too
because from my parents situation was
like
hey stop crying what do you want tell me
what you want this is
and that's honestly the right way but
somewhere along the lines because of
whatever it is new media or however it
happened they're like no you don't want
you don't want your kids to feel these
emotions they don't have to feel that
way you want them to be happy
yeah we want people to be happy but we
want but when you raise a kid
i truly believe that you want them to be
a functioning [ __ ] member of society
that should be your goal they will be
your best friend they will love you
all that other stuff is there if you if
it can be there and i've seen it from
other parents
once again i don't we don't have a kid
yet right yeah but i'm only basing it
off of
like a few people in my life and i'm
just watching them raise their kids
i've seen them face adversity with their
kids the attitude and everything else
but how they've done it was to me from
what i've seen from an outside
perspective
there was a great balance of like
setting boundaries showing that you love
them
and they have that's hard honestly
because we are exhausting yeah we have
different personalities we have
different levels of patient
and we're gonna have different kids they
know the kid that they had they could
have been perfect
like combination but for us it could
have been a whole different thing
yeah i mean it's difficult you know and
having riley
has taught me a lot dude funny [ __ ]
story man
so when we were in san diego we went we
went on this small
we went on this small trip right and you
know
communication is something that we're
always learning
um how to do day by day right i'm
somebody who tends to be very candid and
very blunt
and so when i say these type of things
there's no there's no emotions involved
and i actually found this out through
emails
right when i would write emails with
like people that i'm working with
right and the reason why is because the
people that i'm working with right now
also behave like i do
also it's your position yeah
well equal partners too you know what i
mean so like we all
communicate the same way so well we
built these companies together so
obviously we're very like-minded human
beings
so when we when we talk we say hey i
think this is wrong we don't have to say
hey do you mind if i if i if i kind of
like give you a suggestion we don't have
to do
any of that [ __ ] which is why we can
build and do things a lot faster than
most people
right but it takes a very specific type
of mindset to be able to speak to
somebody like that and not have your
feelings hurt
yes you guys are very similar not only
similar but you guys are also
all male and i think no wait
june anna oh i'm talking about before
june and anna i'm talking about no i'm
talking about this company specifically
so june anna uh carmel there's there's
they're all talk the way we do so it's
like it's very
when we say maybe but they all accept it
the way that we do right so it's like
when we when we say things yeah they
accept it because they understand you
yeah
exactly right so we kind of built the
company around very like-minded people
yeah right
and so like even when we had these me
like hey don't worry about our feelings
you say how you what you think
we could fix it or not right um
obviously it didn't work well with uh
people who were
um you know obviously like you said that
weren't equals in terms of the company
power structure yeah
and so they took it very harsh you know
when there was criticism right and so
having being
being around that i've learned like okay
like communication skills are very
important because
everybody takes an information very
differently and i found out through an
email recently
where there was something wrong with uh
some of our advertisers and i wrote an
email right where it was just
hey you guys said i didn't do certain
things and i wrote and i put it in bold
and captioned
quoted the script that i put out and i
was like oh yeah this is what i
this is what i did so can you can you
point out to me where i did something
wrong
right it's very straightforward when you
re when when i read that it just looks
straightforward but when they read it
they're like oh [ __ ] like hey man i just
want you to know that you're really
i was like hey i wrote back oh did they
write that yeah i wrote back i was like
hey i'm not angry
i'm like 100 i'm not angry i just need
to know that when i reshoot this
um because i thought i did a good job
yeah not to make the same mistake again
so i think when you are in work
environment you and especially something
like that
you go into this yeah you block off all
emotion you just get into facts like
you're almost like a computer
yeah it's like i need to figure out what
i did wrong so i could fix this you know
and so what i had to kind of write to
them is like listen
when we work together just know if i'm
upset in an email
i'll write that i'm upset if you don't
see those words it means i'm happy
funny enough email especially work email
there is a culture exactly the
exclamation points the smiley face
all this other stuff and i kind of wrote
to them like this is not how i do it
just know that if i'm ever upset or
angry i will verbally write it out
if not just assume that i'm really
really happy
oh man have i learned how to write
emails through work
and so you know with with me and her
we're all we also go through those same
communicative
issues like specifically when we're here
in san diego
what happened so tell me we have a dog
named riley
right and so my lovely riley i love her
so so much
she is she does she loves that dog to
death right and so
i was a doctor oh my god
it's a dog and so i it's a special
dog i are you crying right now thinking
about our dog
oh she's really i never loved a dog so
much
yo so with this woman right oh
we're walking the dog and she knows that
i was a dog trainer and you know
i've taught you you are so mean i know
what this is
i was not you you hey we had a mediator
in between oh my gosh
why do you not have napkins here why are
you
why are you crying i don't know because
you love her that much i love her so
much
so you know she doesn't know how to walk
right
i specifically was a dog trainer and i
taught dogs how to walk
all the time and one of the things was
so when she was
she was kind of going crazy and riley
was super anxious and nervous and she
was being dragged around
i was like i was like hey give me the
lease real quick i'm gonna teach her how
to walk
right and so she took that in a very
very personal way
oh yeah and i didn't understand why and
then um
so we have her best friend becky who
knows her very well
and then she could also kind of
translate to me how she feels
so during that moment i was sitting
there and i was like
what is going on you know and she was
like i didn't like the way that you were
talk i was like what do you mean like
i'm
gonna teach our dog how to walk and then
you know
becky was sitting there she didn't
understand either so she had to ask her
some qualifying questions to understand
where she's coming from
and so what it boiled down to for was
from the dog walk it wasn't about the
dog
it was actually about her feeling
her the dog to her is a test for her to
see if she's going to be a good parent
or not
and so when i said i was going to teach
the dog how to walk she felt that she
failed as a parent
so let me go and tell you what exactly
happened there
it is true this whole story is true
just like that email conversation you
had the email culture i think
like you when you were in that mode of
trying to tell me that i need to teach
riley how to i didn't say you need to
i specifically said hey give me the
leash i'm gonna teach
riley how to walk yeah so when you said
that you know how he said it
you said i'm gonna have to teach her how
to walk
i'm going to have i'm gonna have to
teach her
how to walk it's the way you said it
we're saying that
you're gonna have to teach her because
she's not being trained that's how i
received it
and that's how you received it yes the
best that's how you that's how i
received it
and you were saying that to me without
obviously you're you're not thinking
about judging me or anything because
it's not just your dog though
it's our dog so
it is our dog now but the way the fact
is yeah the point was that i got that
dog because i want to know if i could
succeed as a mom or you know get a
little taste of what it's like to be
like a mom
the fact is that just like that email
conversation
and also your work you know seeing who
you're talking to
and how that would affect that person if
i'm pulling away a responsibility
of that person that they want to achieve
let's just make sure that
i'm not taking it away as and saying you
have failed let me go and succeed this
it's just like
let me help you but once again though
like but that's how i receive exactly
that's how you receive the which is fine
right
but i'm just telling you that's
is from zero to a hundred absolutely
there's
absolutely no way from an outside
perspective i would have known
that this is a test of you being a
parent this dog like that right there is
you knew from the
there's no way some somebody would be
like oh
you mean that moment or yeah that moment
there's no way i would say like me
teaching this dog how to walk is me
inferring that you're failing as a
parent
david that is the leap is so cute
and you couldn't explain it to me so i
was sitting there just like yo explain
to me what's going on and then you were
so pissed and i'm like
you gotta explain this to me what's
going on it was a tone that you gave out
to you were in your serious tone
but your serious tone didn't apply well
that's
fine i'm saying that's 100 fine but the
problem is is that in that situation the
reason why
i was so confused is because you
couldn't explain how you were feeling
because i've never been in that
situation but you can understand how
unfair that is it's like
that's true it's very unfair because i'm
because it's not like i disagree i was
like i said
hey i was like i don't know what you
mean what do you mean i think you should
be more
so this is a lesson learned is that oh
my fiance is i think it's crazy
it's just like i should basically
there's a lot more to learn about your
fiance
yeah but exactly but that's why i asked
what do you mean
and you just got more upset and i was
like yo if you can't explain it to me
and you can't talk to me then i'm i'm
lost yeah i mean
okay if you're saying please explain it
to me and all i'm
feeling is that i have failed that's not
something you want to say a lot you
didn't say that either though dear oh
you said i didn't want to
that's how i felt and i didn't want to
say that
but that's not fair to the person that's
asking because now i am at a point where
you just said that i
i should i have to say though becky
understood exactly how i felt she was
like
i heard that i heard that and i
understand
no she didn't she didn't understand what
you were saying she had to ask you a few
questions
and then because she wants to say it
right because she wants me
to say it that's what it was she
understood the feeling
but doesn't and she understood my
feeling but to express it in words
i have to say it that's why she didn't
want to say anything
100 but once again you have to
understand from uh from the other
person's perspective if you can't
explain how you feel and the person's
confused
right i can't i can't understand it so
do you understand it but it's not like
of course that's why we solved it
but then the problem was it's like i
think from you
for you to expect somebody to understand
what you're feeling when you can't even
explain it is very unfair
right but here's the thing though no one
outside no one in my group
in my life would ever say something like
that so it's to begin with it was
shocking
that's understandable but that's still
you know i mean that's in your ideal
world
that's why i'm saying communication is
important and being able to speak
communication is important exactly i'm
communicating though i'm
asking you i'm asking you hey why does
that make you feel bad
and then what did you say i don't know
you're being mean and i'm like hold on a
second
that's i was like wait okay qualifies
that and then you just got more and more
upset and i'm like
okay well i don't okay we're not gonna
get into details here the
conclusion is that we figured out what
the problem was
now from there you understood
where i came from and obviously i
understood where you came from you
didn't you know obviously it wasn't
because for you to attack my emotions or
like
you know what i was trying to achieve
there and you understood where i came
from
so moving forward now you know that oh i
i will not
like you haven't said it so you
understand that you wouldn't say it like
that in the future right
like for example today you didn't do
that you remember like
it was a mess in the beginning so today
we went for a walk again with riley and
as usual it's so hard to go for a walk
with riley because she has
white hair and it gets so dirty and it's
just so much work
on my head that i minimize
has these cute little boots so yeah i
give her i bought these boots
and they're so helpful like her hair
does not get
dirty um and so we went out for a walk
but because i haven't gone
out for a walk with her a lot like she
is just all over the place
and right away david was like this is
not gonna work out and i looked at him i
was like okay and he's like let me
and what did you say i think you said
along the line of let me help you or
like let me let me try to do something
here
whatever the phrase was it didn't stick
in my head where i felt
or it could be that you've already heard
you now you know my intentions
so it allowed you to adjust you know me
even though i may know if you say it the
wrong way it'll stay
so she just proved herself right now
this lady is unreasonable she's an
unreasonable person
and maybe you should know this is how
women are
unreasonable women are
full of emotions okay and that said i
think you did because i also know too
like with dog training um just to go
back what i was saying was like
what people find the biggest thing that
i found out from people that i know that
taught me how to train dogs
was it's not dog training it's people
training
it's it's it's teaching people how to
understand that this is a dog
and it's not your child that is the
hardest thing
riley is no it is it is a dog doesn't
mean that you can't love it like a
family member right but the way that
dogs behave
are not the way the same way that people
behave right and i think
they always feel that when they set
boundaries for these dogs that they're
they're destroying them if they're
hurting them you know
but in a pack in a pack mentality dogs
bite each other's faces if they step out
of line they literally
bite them in the face you know and for
us what we're doing is tugging at leash
and saying
no wait way better than gnawing at their
neck in their face
yeah you know so we're actually doing
like i said it's not
that we're oppressing the dog we are
responsible for this animal in the
public
and it's a reflection of us as a person
and on top of that other people
shouldn't have to deal with our mess and
that goes the same thing with kids
that's why we say when you when people
raise [ __ ] kids you may have to deal
with it in the household but we have to
deal with them in public now
the teachers have to deal with these
[ __ ] kids so that's what i'm always
saying
do you think we're gonna have [ __ ]
kids oh no i'll beat the [ __ ] out of
them
do you think i'm gonna be a
irresponsible parent
because i can't even freaking control my
own dog when we're out in the public i
feel like
it's different and once again you're
making you're comparing apples and
oranges right now
a dog no i'm you are because
a dog and a child are two different
things you
it's going to be different right you and
i are definitely going to clash in the
future in terms of like parenting styles
right because
absolutely because you already know i'm
a lot more strict than probably most
people think that i actually am like i
tend to be
boundaries person right but i think i
like my parents too my parents always
set boundaries
and they were a bit extreme and it
caused a lot of turmoil but the one
thing that was a saving grace for me and
my parents relationship was
they always gave me an abundant amount
of love right it's
you've been to my household the love is
always apparent and it's always there
but if i tell you these stories of how
they treated me like physically beat the
[ __ ] out of me and stuff
they definitely went extreme on that but
like i said the biggest saving grace and
the reason why my parents
and i have about the relationship that
we do now is because they showed
more love than they did hate so that was
allowed that kind of allowed us to mend
our relationship in the future
so i so when people do these things and
they tell me like hey
you don't want to do go too far here
which is true to a certain extent
yeah um but discipline doesn't mean that
you hate your kids discipline doesn't
mean any of that stuff it it
it allows them a frame and a structure
to understand how to react and behave in
society
and if you don't want to do that don't
have a [ __ ] kid don't have a [ __ ]
kid because now i got to deal with your
[ __ ] kid
now i'm the one that has to beat your
[ __ ] kid's ass you know
yeah so that's i mean i don't know
people can agree or disagree but
that's not really something i'm going to
budge on when you have a kid you are
raising somebody that's going to be a
functioning or non-functioning member of
society
that's true that's really what it is you
didn't answer my question though you see
you asked him you basically said that
you are going to be a
responsible disciplined parent i was
like am i gonna be irresponsible you say
it's different no i said it's apples and
oranges because you're comparing how
you're going to be as a parent yeah to
how you behave without
asking you i did answer that
what is it i'll repeat myself again
you're comparing apples and oranges
yes sir no that was the no it's not a
yes or no question it's not black and
white like that then what is it
stop interrupting me i said you're
comparing apples and oranges because
you're thinking that the way that you
are going to raise or treat your child
is the same as this dog and you're not
because a child is different from a dog
so you can't it's cool for you to say
like hey
oh i want to see how i'm going to be a
parent with the stuff it's all different
it's different when you have this
sentient human being that came
out of your womb so so when you asked me
that question of
do you think i i think you'll be
perfectly fine
i don't think that you're that's what i
wanted to hear thank you
don't ask questions expecting what you
want to hear ask a question
um with the knowledge that somebody's
going to answer it that's so yeah
and so like i meant i needed an answer
like that
yeah that's what i mean so like what i'm
saying is that
you can't compare that because
a dog and a human is different right i
know i i wasn't i wasn't comparing it
it's not a good it's not a good
comparison so if you feel like you're
not going to be that type of parent
because
of the way that you treat riley it's
going to be completely different my mom
said too
before she had me and my brother
everybody was surprised that she raised
two kids
because they didn't think that she was
gonna have kids because she was so crazy
i wasn't asking
comparing to riley i was asking as your
fiance
and i wasn't expecting a specific answer
from you
when i asked the question so no need to
lecture me on that
i'm not lecturing you yeah i'm putting
my finger up right now because i'm like
i just wanted to hear
an answer and i was giving you an answer
but it wasn't good
i wanted to clarify that i wasn't
comparing with riley
because you were talking about your
parents their discipline so i was like
okay so what about me then yeah and
i just was wrapping it back to the fact
that you got riley to see if you're
gonna be a good parent
so i'm saying that that those two things
that you shouldn't reflect how you're
gonna be as a parent based on how you
treat riley
as a disciplinarian do you see what i'm
saying so i'm encapsulating the whole
conversation
yeah critical thinking or listening
skills young lady
whatever you love to lecture and why are
you playing footsie with me this is
disgusting he's talking about this
come on this is cute what a conversation
it's hard man like i said we're not
gonna know what we're gonna do when we
become parents because
it's it's all up in the air who knows
like i said like i'm saying who knows my
kids might be a drug dealer or something
but all i know is i'm gonna try my best
and that's all i could out hope and ask
for but there are
some great examples around me like for
example i love i love your cousins
like the way they raise those two kids i
see them
i see the perfect balance of love and
discipline right
they listen to their parents but at the
same time
they they have fun they love their
parents
right they're always smiling they're
happy they have activities and it also
shows how involved they are in their
kids lives
so when somebody tells me that they they
that they don't want to be overly
they don't want to like control their
whole kid's life and set too many
boundaries that's dumb to me that makes
no [ __ ] sense
because those things are neither here
nor there what what is it what does
boundaries have to do with showing your
kid that you love them
like right now you're so concerned that
you want your kid to be best friends
with you because you had a [ __ ] up
relationship with your parents and now
it's going to affect the way that you
raise your kid
yeah in a negative way in my personal
opinion because i've seen it
i've seen the kid i've seen those two
kids specifically
like how they listen to their parents
and how they have some pretty strict
boundaries but they don't resent their
parents at all
like their world is what their parents
built around them and they kind of live
in that in a very happy way
and i appreciate it like these kids
those kids are the happiest kids i've
ever seen in my life they're adorable
they're so adorable so they're super
intelligent super smart
very active a lot of extracurricular
activities and i don't think
at least my cousin didn't grow up like
that so
i was actually shocked to see that
they're playing nerf gun in the house
yeah man the environment that they have
those kids in is like that's the type of
parent that i want to be that was so fun
that was so fun i
really enjoyed that day i would i hope
that we could be that kind of
we are because i'm going to get them
nerf guns i'm going to blast them in the
face
well guys that wraps up this episode of
the genius brain podcast i hope you guys
enjoyed listening
i love you guys very much you can find
muriel at mariel
underscore underscore song and genius
brain every thursdays and sundays
what a very interesting conversation
future parenting who knows
oh yeah and then she cried over a dog i
know i love my riley
oh my god what am i gonna say with my
kids oh oh you're gonna cry all the time
i know
i'm so emotional and we'll see you all
next time
bye peace